hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's a new week in fortnight season X so
as usual we meet up and we look at all
the minor map changes and predict the
future of this battle royale Island this
week is theory heavy so sit your butt
down for 10 minutes use code atom arrow
in the font night shop and let's break
down everything week 8 has to offer for
us
yeah I'm Steiner Hut watch this week we
all know this is more important than
anything else and luckily the Hut is
completely fine this week no
improvements to speak of probably
because Kevin is a purging Junction at
the moment and let's let's be honest
when Kevin gets his pink and purple
backside back down here the huts doesn't
stand a chance
or does it who do you stand with team
Kevin our team Hut watch let's use the
comments below to see who has the
biggest army who are you loyal to I'm
team Hut watch forever oh and by the way
Hut watch is a really good landing
location these days it has a few chests
and so many mats to grab here and also
the people in fatal do not expect you to
be here so don't tell anyone
look watch is awesome just over by Hut
watch is a very strange update from last
week the ice cream van has fallen down
from granny's house that's the weirdest
sentence I've ever said in my life back
in season 1 the ice cream truck was
parked next to the house then the
Pirates came and it was pushed out to
the edge and now three seasons later it
has finally fallen but what could this
mean I'm so confused while you think
about it here's a group of dummy thick
visitors paying their respects
[Music]
yeah I have a very strange fortnight
community but I'm damn proud of them
let's get back over to dusty Depot in
fact the first thing we should say is do
you have the new and improved thick boy
visitor aka the scientist unlocked the
first thick-skinned in Battle Royale I
hope this means that big girls are going
to come over from save the world because
bigger is better baby before I look like
a dirty perv I think the visitor used
the mech parts to build his new suit
ready for fighting the meteor but one
thing I didn't realize is that this
visitor is completely different to the
other visitor from another dimension so
to speak
the scientists kin will play a big part
in today's theory but speaking of those
theories did you watch last week's we
talked about seven dimensions working
together to save the world and a few
days later get this the visitors
description changed to this one of the
seven feet we're on to something boys
here at dusty the potential rocket we
talked about is being assembled right
this moment
hold your horses because this may be the
biggest erection we've ever seen but at
the moment the scientist needs more time
to make his rocket grow so we'll check
back up on him next week around us t
we've seen all the elements to make the
rocket including the thrusters the fuel
lines and I know that you know this but
the Rockets are made from the rift
beacons flipped upside down the
scientist is repurposing the items at
his disposal today something strange was
added though these pieces of technology
it's like the Batcave in here what could
they mean are they here to ignite the
rocket will they be added to the rocket
I don't know
but exciting times ahead one last thing
to notice here up on the scaffolding the
windsock to indicate which way the
breeze is blowing it may be innocuous
but look where it is pointing directly
at the meteor I'm taking this as a sign
for the live event and of course we will
add it to our theory at the end of the
video
now we shall move over to the orb at
this point we usually see another rift
beacon added which then adds to the
pressure of this spherical beast but
this week nothing nada nothing was added
until today over and tilted a rift
beacon has appeared in the same place as
before instead of adding a new area the
visitor is adapting failed areas from
previous rifts beacon attempts which
means the option so later this week
tilted town will be gone so get speaking
like a cowboy out of your system
dagnabbit dog Harnett another Wild West
phrases you Pio [ __ ] sorry about
that we actually do know though what
will happen next in tilted but this is a
bit of a spoiler for the week ahead so
please run to this timecode if you don't
want any spoilers see ya have they gone
they're gone right good and just so you
know I like you guys better than I like
those guys just don't tell them ok so
tilted is getting another crossover with
that man tilted is becoming Gotham City
the leaked loading screen shows us
Gotham but this looks a little bit more
Victorian that I'd expect so maybe it's
taken from Gotham by Gaslight with foggy
streets and steampunk Batman if you want
to see the activities in the Batman
crossover here they are pause the video
to see it for yourself
[Music]
all right you guys have skipped forward
you can come back now I didn't say
anything unpleasant about you at all
okay so Tilted is changing this week but
what about the other areas of the map
well um nothing at all anywhere it's a
very slow week so we're going to build
towards the final event so if there's
nothing else to see we'll do our story
theory but if you see something please
let me know I'm Adam grenade over on
Twitter this week though we are looking
at the Thicke visitor the scientists
bring on the epic music grab the popcorn
and let's do this we always thought we
were the only people on this island no
talk of time-travel are alternative
dimensions but once the visitor opened
our ice and cracked our world we knew
our island is only a small piece of this
giant puzzle when the meteor returned in
season X we all believed the same
visitor had returned with it it looked
like we were right but this visitor is
from another dimension
he owns a new set of skills but once
again uses the rocket to build a plan
setting up home in the last section of
dusty the new visitor began his plan to
stop Armageddon driven by his desire to
destroy the meteor which in his own
dimension destroyed all living beings
replacing them with the undead the husks
the visitor began to reverse-engineer
the brute mechs to discover their power
and after seven weeks of hard work he
was ready creating a new suit capable of
far more than his original suit he also
changed his identity no longer known as
another visitor he became the scientist
slowly his plan became clear the rift
beacons were his attempt to summon help
from other dimensions the seven known
dimensions the weeks passed and slowly
he began to build a crew but nothing
could stop that meteor now the scientist
is building a rocket but for what
purpose
is he Noah and this his ark and he's
taking on board people two-by-two to
evacuate the island back in his world
the scientist had a friend named C
garetty who banished a creature
hell-bent on destruction but before he
could find out her plans she left to the
island maybe starting a new colony on
another planet in another galaxy could
the visitor send others to join her at
this point we don't know but another
option is possible attack aggression the
visitor has made a suit capable of
taking on the meteor but could it be
destroyed in time for days he waged war
on this force of nature but the time
came to make one decision to use the
rocket to escape or use the rocket to
destroy the meteor and end this split
dimension reality he couldn't stop these
events in his own world but can he do it
in this one
[Music]
okay I may have wet myself a little bit
during that what do you think to that
theory I like it I like it a lot I think
last week's was stronger but this is
pretty good
we need a catchphrase for when we finish
these little cinematics consider
yourself theorized okay that sounds
terrible but hit me up if you think you
have a catchphrase we can use on these
ending cinematics I need one anyway can
you believe how different all our
theories have been thank you so much to
everyone who's contributed over the last
few weeks these theories are so good
keep them coming
they are great fun to read to end all
this here's the legends roll call these
guys use code a tomorrow in the font
night shop and you've changed my life
you really have even if you don't use my
code please use someone's because it
makes a huge difference to them thanks
once again you guys
you are leggins to me okay I think we're
done here I'm going to wait for Tilted
to change I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade it's been a pleasure please book
me in next week see ya
[Music]
I hunt I honestly spend half my life
stood up here all the hot watch has
grown so much dude if you are killed by
Kevin you know that I have got your back
I will get revenge on the pink bugger
oh crap up recording well this is
awkward
hi Internet I'm not talking to myself
okay I am see ya